cérémonies officielles commémoration 50
ans après paris revit l'appel du 18-juin
hommage au général de gaulle et à
l'histoire de france
victoire du parti socialiste aux
cantonales partielles de villeurbanne de
tirs des abstentionnistes du premier
tour se sont reportés sur la liste ps et
chef du front national roumanie les
opposants ne désarment pas ils sont
revenus place de l'université
manifestations et affrontements avec les
partisans de ionesco
bonsoir c'est aujourd'hui l'histoire qui
fera l'actualité l'histoire d'un homme
qui s'est confondue avec celle du pays
il ya 50 ans jour pour jour le 18 juin
40 charles de gaulle a osé dire non
simplement non à l'occupant allemand non
à la résignation
aujourd'hui toute la france se souvient
presque toute la france à l'exception
d'un seul parti le front national et
d'un seul homme jean marie le pen qui
garde lui comme modèle et comme
inspirateur le maréchal pétain
toute la classe politique lui rend
hommage et l'image du jour a valeur de
symbole c'était cet après midi à 17h à
l'arc de triomphe
françois mitterrand place charles de
gaulle les deux hommes s'étaient
combattus et vigoureusement au nom de
leurs convictions
au nom des deux france ils ont incarné
sous la vème république
mais aujourd'hui l'histoire semble les
rapprocher françois mitterrand vous le
voyez a dévoilé une plaque reproduisant
le texte de l'appel du 18 juin
un appel que peu de français avaient
entendu mais qui allait heureusement
peser sur le destin du pays
non
le 18 juin 1940 le général de gaulle
seront en cinq journées dans les studios
de la bbc une antenne offerte par
winston churchill ce soir là la france
libre s'exprime pour la première fois la
france occupée écoute et ne sait pas
encore que cet appel la sauvera
reportage à londres michel vial et
georges minois
ici l'on voit général se pose davy vous
les français veulent rester libre à
l'écouté et à vivre ce pari ce défi
ramassés en quelques mots à la fois
sobre et martiaux ne devait pas
seulement réveiller l'esprit de
résistance
il marquait aussi la naissance à londres
d'un véritable phénomène politique et
culturelle autour du service français de
la bbc politique avec la réputation
systématique des mensonges de la
propagande allemande et ensuite un rôle
plus opérationnels à travers des
messages personnels codé culturel avec
le travail d'une équipe turbulente et
espiègle de français venus d'horizons
très divers qui ont eu très vite le
sentiment quotidien de participer à
l'histoire
je prends peine un petit alsacien jeune
officier qui avait dit mais vous vous
rendez pas compte que chez nous en
alsace et en lorraine ce qu'on attend
toute la semaine c'est les 15 secondes
2/10 que vous jouez parce qu'il y avait
une causerie qui passe et le vendredi
pour l'alsace lorraine et avant on leur
jouer bien sûr vous n'aurez pas l'alsace
et la lorraine
on jouait pas automatiquement et bien ce
gars là il avait les larmes aux yeux et
me dise oui c'est ce qu'on attend du
classement
faut bien voir lorsque dans le fond le
rôle de la bbc et du service pensé
pendant la guerre s'est terminée avec
les départements
c'était la fin qu'en 1944 quelque sorte
du rôle de londres le débarquement ça a
été une radio faite par des français
pour des français dans un cadre anglais
ça faut bien le digne cet appel du 18
juin très peu de français l'avait
entendu très peu de français avait
d'ailleurs répondu raison plus pour
rendre hommage aussi aux premiers
résistants ou parmi 100 24 marins de
l'île de sein le 22 juin ils entendent
l'appel du général de gaulle rediffusé à
la bbc il s'embarqueront alors sans
hésiter sur des bateaux de pêche
direction la grande bretagne
ces premiers français libres allaient
devenir les combattants de londres
reportage à rennes sans marque le
vaillant et raymond boudon le 22 juin
pour la première fois les îliens
entendre la retransmission de l'appel du
général de gaulle on est 80 peut-être
boulot notre jeu des vieux train
d'écouter la peine c'était juste avant
midi on avait atteint mais quoi l'appel
du 18 juin et qu'est ce que c'est vous
effet comment vous avez réagi quand vous
avez entendu cet appel ben ça nous
rappelle quelque chose parce que là on a
su qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui épaule et
la tête de la résistance pour des
emplois et qu'on était content de pas
rien et ce sont pratiquement tous les
hommes jeunes ou anciens qui sont partis
c'est à dire tous on ne peut pas dire
l'espace jusqu'à la retraite si vous
voulez ce cas des hommes de 45 50 ans et
ce à une rester sur l'île que des
bouteilles des personnels valises
vraiment à ce moment-là et d'aider trop
jeune l'appel entendu après l'arrêt
nutella weleda quatre autres bateaux le
renard père le roi d armor
le mary stella et le corbeau des mers
par thirau reportant 115 hommes la force
vive du nil 2200 âmes
ce n'était pas très réjouissant donc
pensé bien ni pour ceux qui partaient et
pire encore pour les familles parce que
j'ai souvent pensé à ces et pousse à ces
mères de famille qui sont restés pendant
cinq ont rapidement sans avoir de
nouvelles du continent d'autres senor
répondront à l'appel et à londres le
général de gaulle à cordes khalil un
hommage exceptionnel de vol et mieux
nous ne passions en revue nous voir tout
le monde chacun devait se présenter et
dire d'où il venait et quand il a eu
plus de sens et non qu'ils devront lui
ont dit qu'ils étaient des deux seins il
a sorti sa célèbre phrase ile de sein
ces tongs le quart de la france
et si vous n'avez jamais entendu la voix
du 18 joint n'hésitez pas si vous êtes
apparaît naturellement à vous rendre
place de la concorde les historiens les
architectes et les techniciens radio ont
fait preuve d'une belle imagination
laurence bobillier
pour la 10 place de la concorde un poste
de radio semblable à celui que tous les
foyers français possédait dans les
années 40 la musique indienne et via le
et jeu 18 juin ce qui s'est passé bahia
le général de gaulle qui a passé alors
un message à la france pour dire de
continuer la guerre contre les les
allemands la voix du général de gaulle
des extraits d'un message diffusés par
la bbc
l'histoire cinq ans après l'histoire que
certains ont vécu
je suis tellement ému sais pas quoi vous
raconter quoi 18 juin ça représente quoi
pour vous alors qu'elle fait la guerre
rien parce qu'il a perçu qu'il n'a
entendu ce qu'ils ont entendu ce qu'il
faisait pas la guerre
sig aisée dans leurs fauteuils
j'ai pas entendu l'appel du 18 mai j'ai
entendu l'appel du 24 et je suis
peut-être un des premiers à avoir
entendu gerin de gaulle où l'effet des
libres 1 mais goody dans l'honneur et
dans l'indépendant et d'autres
cérémonies sont prévues à paris et en
france elles nous permettront de ne pas
oublier clément weill raynal
oui et bien paul actuellement nous
sommes ici au sur le haut pont du
carrousel les tribunes sont encore
déserte mais rassurez vous on attend au
moins cent mille personnes pour assister
à partir de 23h au gigantesque spectacle
qui va avoir lieu sur l'eau entre le
pont neuf et le pont du carrousel il
s'agit d'un spectacle son et lumière
avec une série de tableaux évocation qui
vont de l'exode à la libération de paris
sans oublier bien entendu l'appel du
général je ne vais pas vous donner tout
le détail des préparatifs sachez qu'il y
aura 3000 figurants 200 bateaux une
barge de 100 mètres sur l'eau va
reconstituer des scènes de l'exode sur
les routes de france
un avion un vieil avion d'époque un
dragon de havilland va survoler à très
basse altitude les tribunes pour
symboliser pour commémorer le départ
pour londres du général de gaulle voilà
enfin le spectacle doit durer une heure
et quart et il sera suivi d'un
gigantesque feu d'artifice probablement
le plus grand feu d'artifice qu'on n'ait
jamais vue sur paris puisqu'il sera tiré
simultanément de la tour eiffel de la
tour montparnasse des buttes chaumont de
la place d'italie et de la nation voilà
je vous retrouve dans soir 3 où on aura
probablement les toutes premières images
du spectacle
à tout à l'heure retour en 90 avec une
actualité politique marquée par la
victoire de la candidate socialiste face
au représentant du front national à
villeurbanne nicole gauthier obtient
63,29 % des voix soit 12 points de plus
qu'en 1985
principale explication de cette victoire
de tirs des abstentionnistes du premier
tour ont voté pour la liste ps et la
participation globale dimanche dernier
n'a été que de 39% malgré le
retentissement national de ce scrutin
reportage fr3 lyon commentaire albert
ripamonti l'essai non transformé du
front national sont au pea sur
villeurbanne s'est heurté à la
résistance socialiste ce sont les
abstentionnistes du premier tour qui ont
fait la différence
puisque deux tiers des nouveaux votants
se sont reportés sur la candidate ps
preuve que la discipline républicaine a
bien fonctionné et qu'une partie de
l'électorat de la droite classique a été
sensible aux appels d'alain carignon ou
de bernard stasi
quant aux consignes de votes nuls ou
blancs prônée par les états-majors du
rpr ou de l'udf
elles ont été en partie suivi puisque on
relève 500 bulletins menons valable sur
8000 exprimer la conjonction de tous ces
facteurs donne 63% des suffrages à
nathalie gauthier est véritablement une
victoire qui est à la fois m'émeut
beaucoup parce qu'elle représente la
victoire des valeurs de la démocratie et
c'est cela qu'il était important de
démontrer et c'est cela que nous avons
réussi
le front national gagne 10 points par
rapport à dimanche dernier
il récupère ainsi les électeurs du cni
et une partie de ceux du rpr et de l'udf
désorientés par les prises de position
contradictoires des leaders de ces
formations
pierre vial est battu par tous mais dans
certains bureaux du quartier populaire
de bè l'air ou de la cité jacques monod
il obtient entre 44 et 49 % des voix
nous continuons le combat et nous
donnons rendez vous à nos adversaires
aux prochaines échéances de 1991
villeurbanne n'est pas dreux et le front
national n'est toujours pas
l'alternative au parti socialiste
les personnels de radio france de rfi de
fr3 et de lina réunis aujourd'hui en
assemblée générale à l'appel de toutes
les organisations syndicales cfdt force
ouvrière snj cftc cgc et cgt se sont
déclarés solidaires avec les personnels
de la sfp en grève contre le plan de
licenciements prévus par la direction de
l'entreprise une grève reconduite
aujourd'hui à l'étranger situation à
nouveau très tendue en roumanie qui
n'investit tueur officiel de l'yonne
iliescu a même été reportée à mercredi
sur la place de l'université
des dizaines puis des centaines
d'opposants se sont rassemblés pour
demander la démission du gouvernement et
de nouveaux affrontements ont eu lieu
cet après midi avec les partisans du
liège coup de vent une police cette fois
très discrète
sylvie levey de théâtre tout à l'heure
au parlement roumain
les députés votent en faveur d'une
éventuelle intervention des forces de
l'ordre sur la place
jt miction son évacuation définitive
cette opération probable de nettoyage
radical répond à la demande pressante du
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur et du
1er mai lisse et très romane tout avait
commencé hier soir quelques heures
seulement après le départ des gueules
noires 200 golan en train de braver à
nouveau le pouvoir sous le nez du
service d'ordre nude est aujourd'hui au
fil des heures la vague des
contestataires a grossi s'en prenant
même au véhicule du maire de bucarest à
proximité de soldats armés de matraques
et de mitraillettes qui sont restées
muettes elle aussi mais peut-être pas
pour longtemps
ce durcissement du pouvoir apparaît très
contradictoire avec l'amorcé de dialogue
du nouveau ministre de l'intérieur
lancé en direction des manifestants mais
un durcissement qui va dans le sens de
ce qui est en train de se passer à
l'ombre d'un hôpital d'état ou marianne
maltais à nous le symbole du mouvement
estudiantin grièvement blessé lors de
l'attaqué de l'université par les
mineurs du président serait sous mandat
d'arrestation depuis quelques heures
c'est dans un tel contexte de tensions
exacerbées qu aura lieu mercredi
l'investiture dionne iliescu dans sa
fonction de président de la jeune
démocratie roumaine une investiture qui
se promet d'être bruyamment contestées
ouverture demain à la baule du sommet
franco africain mais il y aura si j'ose
dire qu'hier absent de marque le
président guinéen mais aussi le
président ivoirien houphouët boigny et
zaïrois mobutu à l'ordre du jour la
situation politique c'est à dire la
nécessaire démocratisation et
l'effondrement économique franco perpère
la débâcle économique fait vaciller tous
les régimes y compris celui du sénégal
considérées comme démocratiques c'est
qu'au delà de dakar il y a le pays
pauvres vivent presque exclusivement de
l'exportation de l'arachide et le
sénégal est soumis aux mesures
d'austérité du fonds monétaire
international pour résorber 18 milliards
de francs de dettes licenciement de
fonctionnaires chômage clochardisation
du peuple colère le président diouf doit
faire face à une opposition de plus en
plus structuré et déterminé autre pays
dans la tourmente le gabon 1 million
d'habitants sur un gisement de pétrole
de manganèse d'uranium de bois précieux
ce pays aurait dû connaître un
développement semblable à celui du
koweït mais il est dérouté par les
crises sur les matières premières
il est surtout miné par la dictature la
gabegie la corruption effrénée 15
milliards de francs de dettes et bien
sûr plan d'austérité l'insurrection de
port gentil le mois dernier est sans
doute l'un des soubresauts en annonçant
le séisme
le président bongo que l'on voit ici
inspectant 81,9 les dégâts des premières
émeutes s'oriente vers le multipartisme
pour sauver les meubles
en attendant il n'a pas d'autre choix
que la force pour maintenir l'ordre côte
d'ivoire là aussi parti unique au
pouvoir
effondrement des prix du cacao et du
café seule ressource du pays derrière
les tours d'abidjan la misère 15
milliards de francs de dettes et plan de
redressement
le gouvernement veut réduire les
salaires manifestations grèves
arrestation le régime est accusé de
mauvaise gestion et surtout de
corruption du haut en bas de la
hiérarchie aujourd'hui l'état ivoirien
doit nous couvrir à peu près 90
milliards ne pensez pas d'un coup il
n'avait pas les le prouvent les parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas appliqué la loi et
les individus qui sont sales et
d'appliquer cette loi ne peut pas
l'appliquer contre eux mêmes les années
90 risque d'être donc pour ce pays
autrefois modèle l'ère des
bouleversements environnement jusqu
alors les bactéries laver plus blanc
elles viennent maintenant à bouder marée
noire au large du texas une partie de la
nappe de pétrole échappée du méga board
en effet disparu littérale non digérés
par des bactéries répondu en pleine mer
expérience efficace donc mais attention
pas de solution miracle
les mangeuses de pétrole sont très
sensibles à l'environnement chantal
croire les enzymes gloutons appliquée
aux marées noires
c'est ainsi que vous pourrez caricaturer
l'opération menée au large du texas avec
des premiers résultats prometteurs
le principe les bactéries projeter sur
les nappes transforme les molécules de
pétrole en émulsion d'acides gras
inoffensif elmer ensuite quand elles
n'ont plus rien à manger
90% du pétrole serait ainsi dévoré en 24
heures c'est la première fois qu'une
telle méthode est appliquée grandeur
nature
or des labos il semble qu'il ne reste
quasiment plus de pétrole dans la
première zone testée selon des
responsables texan pourtant il faut
rester prudent et attendre les résultats
de l'épandage de dimanche
ea ne prouve en effet que la disparition
du pétrole n'est pas dû au courant ou un
déplacement des bouées autre bémol
autre point à vérifier ces
micro-organismes survivre et tyloo
agirait-il dans un autre environnement
dans des conditions climatiques
différentes
une question que se posent notamment les
chercheurs français qui eux exploitent
une autre méthode
elle consiste non pas à apporter des
bactéries mais à nourrir d'autres
bactéries
déjà présente dans la mer pour l'heure
le méga borg a perdu moins de soixante
mille litres de pétrole petite marée
noire mais qui apportera sans doute de
grands enseignements
pascal justice résume les autres
événements du jour couvert en france par
notre réseau régional
on a frôlé le drame ce matin à la sortie
de zone où un bus scolaire a pris feu le
car transportait 48 personnes dont 19
enfants quand le chauffeur a entendu
l'explosion du moteur à l'arrière il a
stoppé le véhicule et fait évacuer ses
passagers très tôt à l'histoire finit
bien puisqu'il n'y a aucun blessé mais
on ne peut s'empêcher de penser à
l'accident d'autocar de juillet 82 qui
avait fait 53 morts dont 46 enfants ici
même à poney
le procès des quatre contre terrorisme
du gal qui a débuté hier à pau aura bien
lieu malgré la demande de renvoi des
avocats
un cinquième homme considéré comme le
commanditaire des deux attentats manqués
en 85 contre des basques espagnols est
incarcéré à madrid et les juges ont
estimé que sa présence n'est pas
indispensable à la manifestation de la
vérité à sa détiennent près de lyon une
entreprise de matières plastiques a pris
feu treize mille mètres carrés réduit à
néant
on ne connaît pas la cause du sinistre
la fermeture de l'établissement entraîne
le licenciement de 500 salariés
la municipalité a proposé en
remplacement les anciens abattoirs de la
ville avait bien fait après midi à
l'elysée pour défendre les sans abri il
s'est entretenu 40 minutes avec le chef
de l'état pour rappeler qu'il est urgent
de débloquer les moyens nécessaires pour
enrayer la news r s'il a aucun risque
mais c'est à dire sur la menace d'être
attaqué demain à une de nos frontières
dans la journée en or et l'argent les
matières premières les hommes les
machines et tous gagné 6,1 pour faire
face
fausse alerte à verdun où depuis 24
heures on a demandé aux habitants de ne
plus boire l'eau du robinet à l'origine
de cette mesure la mort d'une truite
servant à tester la qualité du liquide
aujourd'hui les examens de laboratoire
plus approfondies ont démontré que l'eau
de verdun est bien potable
le doyen masculin des français monsieur
henri pérignon est décédé hier près de
deauville à 110 ans il avait reçu il y a
deux jours les insignes de chevalier de
la légion d'honneur coupe du monde de
football match spectaculaire ce soir
entre la roumanie et l'argentine vous
aurez des images et le résultat dans
soir 3 nous a paru intéressant de suivre
l'équipe de roumanie et d'observer son
comportement les joueurs qui jouent
aujourd'hui jouait déjà sous le
précédent régime celui de ceausescu
comment vivent t-il l'évolution des
événements roumanie en quête de jean
philippe guillin 9 juin 90 pour la
première fois le nouvel hymne aux
roumains près zone dans un stade italien
15 novembre 89
un mois avant la révolution line repris
en choeur par le public de bucarest est
différent les paroles sont de nicolae
ceausescu
pour prévenir tout débordement de la
foule la police parade avant le coup
d'envoi d'un match capital pour la
sélection roumaine qui doit
obligatoirement vaincre le danemark pour
espérer aller au mondial et dans la
tribune d'honneur valentin ceausescu
fils du dictateur
l'éminence grise du football roumain
doter de moyens financiers très
importants
il suit constamment l'équipe nationale
et n'hésite pas dit-on à verser
personnellement des primes aux
principales vedettes du ballon rond le
football c'est sa véritable passion
les joueurs le lui rendent bien après le
but de la victoire 3-1 face aux danois
il se retourne vers lui et le salut
personnellement c'est du délire dans le
stade après le traditionnel tour
d'honneur valentin ceausescu se joint
aux joueurs pour fêter avec eux la
qualification à gauche à côté de l'ong
le gardien de but l'homme avec le
chapeau c'est stefan kovacs
l'ancien entraîneur de l'équipe de
france de l'agonie à l'extase il n'y a
qu'une seule marche
merci à tous de nous avoir été mais plus
spécialement à monsieur valentyn faut
tout ce qui nous apprenons que valentino
et nicolas hadji le meneur de jeu et le
buteur de la roumanie sort sous les
vivats et it le stade à bord de sa
mercedes
aujourd'hui valentin ceausescu est en
prison il attend l'ouverture de son
procès l'acca tous lungu hadji défendent
maintenant les couleurs de la roumanie
de yoni escou question était il obligé
de fraterniser aussi ouvertement avec la
dictature
valentin ceaucescu a vraiment bien
travaillé pour le football roumain mais
c'est dans son entourage que les gens
n'étaient pas correctes je parle bien
sûr de ceausescu lui même mais aussi de
tous ceux qui ont utilisé les bons
résultats de nos footballeurs pour
servir la dictature en tout cas à ce
soir mes garçons jouerons sereinement et
ils rentreront sur le terrain sans états
d'âme d'un coup de blues
fin de ce 19 20 vous retrouverez demain
élise lucet seul je vous retrouverai de
mon côté je dis 21 juin en direct de
prague à 19 heures puis à 20h30 à
l'occasion de la fête de la musique que
nous diffuserons en direct de la
capitale le tchécoslovaque pourra
entendre julien clerc jean louis aubert
ou véronique sanson mais ce ne sera pas
une simple émission de variétés elle
aura une forte dimension politique nous
inviterons tous les artistes
tchécoslovaque qui ont participé à la
révolution démocratique à la révolution
de velours et nous aurons un duplex
exceptionnelle entre deux présidents
l'un de l'est
vaclav havel l'autre de l'ouest françois
mitterrand un dialogue donc en direct le
21 juin à 20h30 entre les deux chefs
d'état avant cela les programmes sur
l'a3 ce soir à 20h35 du cinéma avec d'un
film d'espionnage britannique
l'homme qui n'a jamais existé à 22h15
l'ex sacrifié un documentaire qui relate
l'histoire vraie d'honorer d'estienne
d'orves et de ses compagnons enfin
dernier rendez vous faut avec
l'information 23h10 soir 3 présenté par
marc hautement bonsoir bonsoir à demain
on
toulouse